foreign
we're going to start this hour with
Selena in Orlando Hi Selena how are you
hi I'm doing well I'm really excited to
be talking to you great how can we help
um so I I recently I'm married I'm 28 I
live in Orlando and our household income
is 155
000. and we just had a baby and we were
living in a really small condo and kind
of needed more space really quickly so I
was through all of my 403b about 26 000
to cover the down payment and the
closing costs I think when we saw our
current home I'll get about 26 to 30 000
back
um but now I'm I'm a new listener and
realize I'm kind of going didn't follow
any of the baby steps and I'm just
wondering what advice like you would
give us um in terms of having a bit of a
higher mortgage payment now and then
also needing to kind of rebuild
retirement or starting a bit from
scratch
ouch
well it's not got anything to do with
the baby steps you've screwed yourself
um you've really made yourself a mess
because if you do not uh redeposit the
26 000 within 60 days of the time you
took it out you're going to be charged
your tax rate plus a 10 penalty on this
and so you're going to lose 40 percent
of that money in taxes and penalties
okay translation
thirteen thousand dollars
twelve thousand dollars is going to
government
okay so when you sell your house you
need to set aside enough to cover the
mess you made when your tax bill comes
next year
um and then the rest of that money will
be used for
uh wherever you are I guess in your
situation but yeah this uh you borrowed
money for a down payment at forty
percent interest is what you did
okay yeah I was hoping like with the tax
name like this like we'll have a baby on
there and this is the first year we'll
be filing like you can't offset this
level a mess okay babies don't babies
don't cover this no okay not even close
so this is yeah you really stepped in it
um so oh my gosh uh how long ago did you
pull the money out
um
let's see where in July so maybe about a
month ago
but um the the house that we're having
built won't be done until end of
September and so I'm trying to time the
selling of this house to the closing why
did you pull the money out if you
haven't closed on your other house
I needed the money for the down payment
so you put the down payment first and
then they for them to start building and
then it's not a down payment it's a
deposit
okay
okay yeah so I had to put five percent
of the of the house five percent of the
cost of the house I had to give that to
them in order for them to start building
it yeah and then if your house doesn't
sell now you got two house payments and
you're double screwed
well the other houses in the town home
have been going for like 30k more than
what I originally paid for it and so I'm
hoping to get like a bigger when when
this house does sell yeah if interest
rates took up a point by September by
the time you get your house on the
market and the market freezes like a
deer in the headlights you've really
messed yourself up I'm scared for you
honey I'm scared
um you guys have done you guys got
completely impulsive and you impulse the
house and it made and made itself a mess
potentially I hope you get out of it
with your skin intact but I'm not
positive you're going to so anyway what
can we do from here uh I assume you gave
them twenty six thousand dollars right
I gave them 16. okay so you have ten
yeah and then I had savings already so I
have about 17 000 in savings
Plus 10.
no to 17 in total I had seven already oh
you had seven okay all right and you
don't have any other money
um
no I mean no you have Investments of any
kind that are not mutual funds are there
not uh retirement accounts
I maybe uh three months ago I opened up
a 529 for my daughter how much is in it
probably about three thousand okay
because every dollar we can put back in
that 403 b before the 60-day Mark is not
going to be taxed or penalized and so
I'm going to scrape nickels out of the
corner of the couch and try to get as
close to 26 000 back in there because
every dollar you put in there is going
to save you 40 cents
you follow me okay ten thousand dollars
if you can put ten thousand dollars in
there saves you four grand
and the four grand is just burned up it
just went to mist it didn't it didn't
accomplish anything except to allow you
to buy something you weren't ready to
buy
and didn't need to be buying but you're
there now so yeah you need to scratch
together as much as you can and put it
back uh go to ramseysolutions.com and
click on smartvester and find a
smartvestor pro that helps with
investing in your area that we recommend
and they'll help you try to get this
undone and get as much money back in
that account before that 60 day Mark as
you can to keep from getting hammered
with a 10 penalty plus your 30 tax rate
40 cents on the dollar okay now then the
rest of this is we're gonna have to put
you on a game plan where you got to stop
buying things you can't afford
and uh and buying them out of order
because you just and you justify it with
a lot of emotion because you had a baby
babies don't take up that much room
they're not that big
and so
this is just complete
um normal stuff I'm not mad at you honey
I'm scared for you and I really want you
to not have a mess because by this time
next year if you've got two house
payments and a 13 000 tax bill all
because you bought a house and can't get
your house sold you got a mess on your
hands you've set your family up for a
real problem here unless you unless this
just unfolds perfectly for you so let's
uh get with a smartvester pro and get
this turned around I say Dave I'm
following you would you suggest that you
didn't say it so that's why I'm asking
pulling the 3000 out of the 529 adding
to every dollar I can find so it's not
in a retirement account right in this
case she's got 17 in savings she puts
the three on top of that she's at 20.
does she keep a thousand in it baby a
thousand dollars so now we're at 19. how
does she come up with seven thousand in
30 days before she gets penalized only
on seven thousand not on twenty six
thousand I like this and so if it's if
I'm hearing you and I hope you're
hearing this Selena I mean we got we got
yeah Budget on a beans and rice thing
and start replenishing your your savings
account very very quickly but I like
getting taxed on seven versus twenty six
and penalized at 40 percent on the
dollar yeah wow so yeah this is this is
you do not use your retirement account
people yeah you do not use it for
anything except retirement because and
the system is designed to punish you
beyond belief if you do and it ain't
cool it ain't cool it's not okay
you know it's not funny it's not fun
it's it then there's no rationalization
you know babies don't take up that much
room slow down sell your house when your
house sells take that money buy a house
if you want to build a house then take
that money move into an apartment and
use the money from the sale of your
house for your deposit on the new
construction but
um yeah you got sucked into new house
fever bad instead of taking a cold
shower you got yourself in a mess
oh I'm sorry hun